his rhetoric has caught the interest of
Americans I think in part because he's
speaking in a kind of bombastic style
that Taps into the kind of you know us
versus them tribalism that's on the rise
here I want to take a quick look at a
rant he went on against
leftists who he says have ruined
Argentina's economy
foreign
Los hurdles
it's an intense captivating clip uh do
you agree with his sentiment that in
Argentina you can't negotiate with the
leftist Coalition because they'll use
the state apparatus to squelch that
debate and take everything away from you
um
can I go all right go ahead
all over Latina
when the left doesn't win in the in the
elections they completely destroy the
country we have seen it in Chile we have
Syria in Colombia we've seen it also in
in Brazil with the support to Lula so
the left is obsessed with with ruling
from democracy when they win or by
making a lot of uh
um by making the
violence in the in the streets I I also
agree with how melee communicates
because he's engaging for decades we
have seen Libertarians uh saying well
yeah we have the right ideas but no
passion at all and here comes a guy with
a lot of passion now the fact that we
are adopting terms like cultural battle
worries me because this is exactly what
the Nazis or the fascists did they want
to state to to implement a culture by
law a culture of hatred and then he says
we are morally Superior than the than
this than the Shiri socialists
that libertarianism is morally Superior
hell objectivism is morally Superior
because it it tells you that individuals
are not uh animals of sacrifice to the
state or the church now
Libertarians I can say are morally
Superior because they you know defend
the individual when Javier melaye adopts
conservatism religious Estates and he
talks about a moral superiority
I am worried if he is going to use the
state in order to implement one kind of
culture so what are we talking about
there and he even says we are
aesthetically Superior because he says
that people in the libertarian movement
are are more pretty than all these women
in the marxists collectivists that are
not even like shaving their legs or
whatever and I'm like yeah okay yeah the
market makes us prettier but those are
libertarian stance so then again I think
now that Javier melee is taking
International protagonism
we have a massive opportunity to educate
people in the United States and in Latin
America of what libertarianism is about
so if he governs and when he governs we
can be very very accurate because when
I'm worried what I really don't want it
to happen is that if he comes to govern
cover government and he betrays Liberty
people will blame Liberty instead of
blaming him which is what happened with
Pinochet it's been a headache for
Libertarians all over the region to to
you know like take ourselves away from
that Pinochet dictatorship which was a
capitalist dictatorship and and as Mario
vargasiosa said there is no such thing
as a good dictatorship and a bad
dictatorship all are bad so I am very
worried that if Libertarians don't take
this opportunity worldwide if he comes
into power and Liberty is betrayed
people will blame neoliberalism
capitalism when when they are not the
ones to be blamed the issues that kind
of led to malays rise which I think are
largely the economy the Central Bank um
and the way that the political class or
I think as you put it the cast that uh
is the way Malay frames it I've got I've
pulled one more clip that I think will
take us into that discussion which um is
uh melee uh again uh directing a lot of
passion and anger with very heated
rhetoric but in a direction that I think
a lot of Libertarians would agree is
warranted at corrupt political Elites so
let's take a look at this and discuss
cultural
is it is foreign
foreign
so I mean the person who first shared
that clip with me commented that it
almost seems ripped from the pages of an
Iran novel I want to start with Gloria
this time but Eduardo you can share any
thoughts too just what are your
reactions to melee's message there I
absolutely agree I actually I have said
the same thing in different words in
many forums because in Latin America the
majority of people do not understand
that the government doesn't produce
wealth there is a misconception that the
government is sort of like a magic
spaceship where money is magically
created and the politicians Grant you
with resources and money that magically
they possess you know people do not get
the basic idea that every cent that the
government has is because they have
taken even violently from the people who
produced it so if you don't understand
that the politicians are your employees
and you think that they are the kings
that Grant you rights and Grant you
resources of course you blindly obey to
whatever they they are going to say and
of course the politicians are going to
have a Keynesian mentality because that
technician mentality is the one that
grants them all the powers to control
the economy it is really rare to have a
politician that is going to have a free
market approach so I I absolutely agree
and about
um politicians being sociopaths I've
said this multiple times I think that we
need to have uh not only analyze our
politicians by the resume but we should
also have them for what Eduardo said
emotional intelligence tests
psychological tests because I believe
that Latin America has been governed by
narcissists and sociopaths and I always
say when people tell me because of the
way that I express myself right that
they say oh you you have mental problems
and I'm like yeah I am you know like I I
have no problem to be you know tested in
in Psychology tests or MRI or whatever
but just please make it very neutral
because if you put me with conservative
shrinks or with social strings of course
they're gonna declare me crazy right but
I do believe that emotional intelligence
is something that the world needs in
their leaders you know and not only in
Latin America worldwide it is something
that is highly needed hey thanks for
watching that clip from my conversation
with Gloria Alvarez and Eduardo Marti
about the rise of Javier melee in
Argentina for the full conversation
click right here for another clip from
that conversation go right here